a growing number of people are concerned
about food safety after a series of
recalls over food contamination Kraft
Heinz has voluntarily recalled 7,000
cases of taco bell's salsa con queso
mild cheese dip out of botulism concerns
there have been no reports of illnesses
associated with the product and we
reported yesterday pepperidge farm is
voluntarily recalling more than 3
million packages of goldfish crackers
over possible salmonella contamination a
company told us only four varieties may
be tainted and no confirmed illnesses
have been reported the ingredient that
may be contaminated with the bacteria is
the whey powder in the seasoning
Mondelez international also issued a
voluntary recall of 16 varieties of its
Ritz cracker products because of the
same concerns over salmonella the FDA
says it is investigating there is no
evidence that the products are
contaminated Michael Moss is an
investigative journalist who want to
Pulitzer Prize for his reporting on
contaminated food and he joins us at the
table to hopefully alais some fears
because I know every parent I know has
the goldfish and Ritz crackers at home
normally when you think of Salmonella
Michael I think of Turk raw turkey or
chicken how is it possible in goldfish
crackers
so the issue here is the way which is
this liquidy by-product for making
cheese and Greek yogurt they turn it
into a powder which is something of a
miracle ingredient for these these
companies that do taste the protein it
makes that it helps the texture and
holds things together um the problem
comes when you introduce water or
contaminant like seminole into the
factory making that way um that can
spread the pathogen and create a problem
for the company using that as an
ingredient is this easily preventable
yeah the companies need to be more
diligent about inspecting their
suppliers because they're using this
global food chain of ingredients over
which they don't have enough control so
they don't know who their suppliers are
and they need to personally go in and
check when there's a problem like this
so it may not be an individual company
it may be a lot of companies are using
the same way suppliers yeah absolutely
and middlemen get in the middle and they
will assemble things together and then
sell them to the big food giant so it's
it's a complex problem and is that what
makes it so hard to chase back to the
the lane and figure out where it started
yeah the traceback is a big issue
especially when you get sick I mean a
million people are getting sick from
food every day every year but very few
of them find out what it is they ate
that happened because the symptoms can
come 72 hours later you go the doctor
and the doctor goes what did you eat and
nuts the end of the story Michael you're
such a proponent of eating real food so
you think about well let me cut out
these processed foods like these
crackers and maybe I'd be safe but then
we had that huge e.coli break out with
with lettuce so how does a consumer
protect themselves you can't trust
anybody but yourself so lettuce you
rinse you peel you wash and maybe
depending on how much risk you want to
take you double think about what you're
eating I mean I love oysters I'm never
gonna give them up but there are people
who say the risk in oysters is too great
for them so what we call czar up though
just in general why do you think that is
you know we really don't know it could
be that the companies are being more
diligent it could be that there are more
investigators out there for state health
departments doing a better job or there
could be an increase in incidence we
don't know at this point but I do think
it's important to say it like over
history our food is incredibly safe yes
absolutely yeah they do these are rare
incidents that we're hoping to see
decline steadily over the years it's not
go up were you even consider even you
surprised that there was a recall about
goldfish and Ritz crackers did that
surprise you or do you think as an
expert why I understand how this happens
not really because I started writing
about food safety 10 years ago when
there was there was problem in pathogens
and peanuts flour it turns out to be a
big risk for pathogens that's why you
never want to eat raw cookie dough you
don't know you want to cook it have you
tasted raw cookie dough mr. ma I do and
I love it and it takes all the willpower
in the world not to like put my finger
in the bowl and my kids are making
chocolate chip cookies that's good at
our house with this the entire bowl gets
consumed so just a finger is no
extraordinary move dude all right
thanks how much my demise